That may be Robbie. I'm looking for the first yellow, followed by blue, and
swap them. That would be bby, byy. And again, the first yellow followed by
blue, and swap them, and I'm at [BLANK_AUDIO] yyy and I'm done. Now, the
sequence is in order, all the blue ones come before all the yellow ones. So,
Robbie has used this algorithm here to clean up the Legos. Now, this is a great
example, again, of an algorithm. You have a sequence of steps, each of them is
unambiguous, each of them is something that Robbie can do. And eventually, the
Legos are all cleaned up. It's actually not totally obvious why the Legos are
always cleaned up when you execute the sequence of steps, but they are. Now,
you've seen algorithms and pseudo code first with numbers, then with Lego
blocks. And now, you get to practice the Lego blocks a little bit more with
Sarah. Have fun.